daniel léger c'est un junkie sans
ambition qu'il ment comme il respire est
son seul but dans la vie se défoncer le
film suspect numéro un est une fiction
basé sur l'histoire vraie d'alain
ollivier un excellent et norman
soupçonné puis accusé de trafic
international d'héroïne citoyen canadien
est exécuté dans un pays du tiers-monde
et aux condamnés à mort il a finalement
été libéré après huit ans dans une geôle
thaïlandaise les premiers coups j'ai vu
l'image d'antoine écrit chaînes aux
pieds comme moi je les avais chez nous
chercher on cherche à élargir nos
opérations on aimerais tu nous aides
tu t'en vas en thaïlande alain ollivier
s'était piégée dans une opération de
type mr big menée par la grc
une opération ou mallet de plusieurs
irrégularités quelque chose qui peut
indignée la population parce que quand
quelqu'un de très très haut placés dans
le crime organisé fait des menaces à un
citoyen tu crains pour ta vie que tu as
peur mais ça peut inciter à dire un peu
n'importe quoi à dire oui à n'importe
quoi wafa n'importe quoi il ne doit sa
survie qu'à la crinière site plus du
journaliste denquête victor malaret
crime de noix deux jours sur place et je
reviens avec un scandale national j'ai
envie que ça ouvre un dialogue sur le
droit du mans puis d'intelligence poser
des questions en général sur n'importe
quel sujet qui entendant l'hymne dans
les médias puis c'est ce que le
journaliste victor malheur est que fait
il ya vu cet article le plus de
questions
il y avait une creuse et qu'aujourd'hui
sauver la vie de quelqu'un et la
détermination il en a fallu au
réalisateur daniel roby à qui on doit
entre autres le film louis cyr puisque
ça lui a pris 13 ans pour pouvoir
produire son film c'est devenu comme le
film le plus important si on veut
jusqu'à présent sur laquelle j'ai
travaillé parce que les embûches pour le
faire était compliqué mais le sujet
derrière en valait la peine
allez olivier espère que son histoire
porté à l'écran contribuera à faire
changer des choses qui nous inciter à
prendre la vie avec philosophie
peut-être justement que le chum cela va
permettre au gendre et est logique
à comparaître ont fini comme aux lettres
le brouillard soit rien d'agréable
médicaux films en format de quelques
jours après sa sortie au canada
le film prendra l'affiché à
l'international ici des directions de
recherche aussi et radio canada montréal